It seems we you're bound to repeat history and what his old becomes new again.
Why is it that we can't seem to find equilibrium within a society?
Ideas begin with good intentions,
but lead towards the extreme.
Yeah.
Well,
the reason that we can't find equilibrium is because the environment that we
live in isn't an equilibrium.
And so I,
I kind of imagine it this way.
It's like we're,
we're traversing the back of a giant,
this is obviously a symbolic reference of the giant serpent and it's,
and it weaves back and forth and you don't know at any moment which way it's
going to curve and turn.
And so sometimes it turns to the right and sometimes it turns to the left.
And what that means politically is that sometime we have to turn to the right
and sometimes we have to turn to the left.
And we don't know exactly when those,
um,
what new call,
we don't know exactly how to time that.
And so what we all have to do is keep our eyes open and tell the truth and
discuss things with each other that are,
especially with people who have political beliefs that are different than us,
so that we can ensure that we haven't tilted too far one way or the other.
And that's why I'm an advocate of free speech or one of the many reasons I'm an
advocate of free speech is because it's the continual dialogue between people of
different temperamental types that keeps us oriented as close as we can come to
the center of the serpents back.
And so there is no permanent equilibrium.
There's only the equilibrium that's produced by continual negotiation and a
democracy is a formalized negotiation.
And so,
um,
and,
and it's free speech that keeps it healthy and alive.
So,
um,
there's no permanent equivalent equilibrium state except death,
you know,
and,
and it's always negotiation in relationships too.
Like if you have an intimate relationship or a familial relationship or even a
friendship,
there's no final equilibrium state.
You have to communicate with each other honestly,
all the time,
and keep the relationship moving to adjust the environment that the relationship
is operating in.
That's how it stays alive.
And in an intimate,
longterm,
intimate relationship,
like a marriage,
it's a continual,
uh,
it takes continual effort.
Uh,
I mean,
it's worthwhile effort and,
and that,
but you have to be conscious and awake to keep your relationship alive and you
have to be communicating all the time.
Well,
maybe not all the time because you can over communicate to,
but,
um,
so,
well,
so that's why we can't reach a state of permanent equilibrium.